the rugby league has uh now banned males
from competing against females in
international competition
and 60 minutes australia did a story
about this
and i want to play this story for you if
you're only listening to the audio
you're not going to be able to fully
appreciate this because you got to see
the video so go to youtube or go
dailywire.com and watch the video too um
this is not supposed to be a parody
they interview hannah mouncey who's a
male who identifies as a woman plays
rugby is now going to be excluded from a
lot of these competitions a lot of these
uh rugby matches
and
we're you're supposed to watch this
interview and think that hannah mouzy
is the victim and that it's absurd that
he would be uh excluded
but it's kind of hard to come to that
conclusion just based on the visual
let's watch
do you accept the afl's argument that
you do have a size advantage over some
of your opponents i think the biggest
issue is not necessarily that i'm too
big or too strong now
it's more
okay you're already big ready strong
whatever
but what if you were to get into that
elite training environment
and that would build you up put on an
extra 15 kilos and you just
push everyone aside but physiologically
that's just not going to happen
the people who seem to have the biggest
problem with this is male administrators
but the female competitors haven't
raised their voices at all lisa watson
knows better than most what hannah's
going through she's a doctor who
specialises in transgender health issues
and is also a transgender athlete
after two years of hormone replacement
therapy she says hannah's body has no
residual benefits from her time as a
male
prior to her transitioning she had a v8
motor powering this
big
muscle
frame
now she's transitioned and her
testosterone level has dropped and her
muscle mass has decreased and her
strength and
stamina has decreased she's now got a
little four-cylinder engine so she's
actually at a physical disadvantage
dr watson suspects there are other more
sinister factors at play
i'm just wondering whether they did not
want to have someone like hannah
representing their new league
they wanted
a presentable
beautiful
female
who could be
the face of afl
a trans woman may not be
what they desired
okay i had to actually take notes
because there's so much nonsense here
that we need to pick apart in that uh
less than two minute clip there
um
first of all we'll start with the trans
person the other the older person saying
that uh well female competitors they're
not complaining
well yes they are complaining first of
all
uh they they have complained in all of
these sports
but then the other part of it is that
um it when if and when they do complain
they are shouted down
and called bigots by people like you
so you've got a metaphorical gun to
their head and then you're saying look
at that they're not complaining while
you point the gun right at their head
and you're muttering under your breath
to them you better not complain
you see they're not complaining
i mean if they do complain we'll destroy
their lives of course and it will just
rip them to pieces
but they're not complaining
no it's it's even in spite of that there
are still women who are
speaking out
and many more should and hopefully will
in the future
also we're told by
the um
the reporter there that hannah mouncey
has no residual benefits
and again you have to see the visual to
really appreciate this and in fact you
can go to google and just look up hannah
mounty and to see the the spectacle
of this guy competing against women in
rugby it's ridiculous like you would you
another thing from the left where when
you first see it you think it must be a
joke this must be from no it's this is
real hannah mouncey in spite of all the
uh
the hormones presents and everything
else
hannah mouzy is
six foot two
hold on i just had it up here i want to
i want to get hannah mountz's statistics
okay
six foot two
220 pounds
no residual benefits in rugby against
women
what's the average um height and weight
of a of a of a female um five feet four
inches and 170 pounds
okay
five feet four on average
versus six foot two
220 pounds versus 170
on average
no residual benefits
it's just
it's just total absurdity the the truth
is right there in front of your face as
always
and they are and you're looking right at
it and they are telling you no that
doesn't exist it's like you're it's like
you're you're standing in front of a
brick wall
okay and hannah mouzy is basically a
brick wall compared to these uh to these
women that he's competing against
but it's as though you're standing in
front of a brick wall and actually
banging your head against it and they're
sitting there telling you oh that brick
wall doesn't exist no it doesn't it's
actually not there
then you're supposed to just accept that
okay
and then the other part of this too i
mean we could we could talk about
um
just how dishonest and disingenuous all
this is women aren't complaining yeah
but when they do you destroy them no
residual benefits that's ridiculous and
we can talk about all those issues
but also i don't want to gloss over
just the um
how they sort of casually admit
the ways that um
this gender so-called gender transition
destroys your body
so you have this other guy
just casually admitting this
oh well yeah he's been on all these
drugs and everything so he's a lot
weaker he's he's not as powerful
well he's no i assure you his body's
been destroyed
by by transition
and that's supposed to be a good thing
now i i
agree with that i don't deny that
they are correct that when you get on
the hormone drugs and everything else
and you start the transition you are
destroying your body
and you are whether you're a man or a
woman you are depriving yourself
of many of the benefits of being a man
or a woman
you're taking away a lot of the
inherent power that you would have in
that identity as a male or a female
you're stripping all of that away and in
return you're getting nothing
so a woman as she transitions
she takes away her female form her
breasts her ability to conceive children
all of that her feminine beauty all of
that is out the window
and in replace she gets nothing
she doesn't get the power and strength
of a man she doesn't even get the
appearance of a man um she doesn't get
the biological capacities and abilities
of of of a male she gets none of that so
she's lost much of what makes her a
woman though she still is a woman and
she gets none of what makes a man a man
and she just ends up with nothing
so it's a bargain where you give up
everything and you get nothing in return
like a literal deal with the devil is
what it is
and it's the same thing for a man
and they admit that like we're
like they're proud of it like it's a
good thing
no what you're describing that's all the
more reason why this doctor should not
be doing this to people
and they get away with that
like
they can
most the time they will admit or rather
they will they will refuse to admit that
gender transition destroys the body
the only time they'll admit it is in
this context
when they're trying to defend the idea
of males competing against females and
sports
and then they'll freely admit it and say
oh no his body's completely ruined i
assure you everything's fine
absolutely grotesque well before you go
hit the subscribe button and ring the
bell and while you're at it if you want
to go watch or listen to my full show
head to dailywire.com and subscribe you
can also catch my show on spotify apple
podcast or wherever you get your podcast
so go check it out now i demand it
your compliance is somewhat appreciated
you